la mine ça fait combien de temps au fond
euh 32 ans j'ai toujours travaillé au
fond alors j'ai au à la mine j'ai j'ai
gravé tous les stade comme au football
j'ai essayé de concilier les
[Musique]
deux Mons dombrovski bonjour oui c'est
c'est fini bah c'est fini
ouais un peu nostalgique euh de faire
mon dernier poste on va aller par làbas
il Ain bruit ou ce n'est pas au bout de
32 ans de service ce n'est pas au bout
de 32 ans de service qu'on quitte son
métier si on l'aime bien un cœur
joyeux bien sûr longemps que vous y
pensez là ben non je n'y pense pas ça
venu comme une bombe j'y pensais mais je
n'y croyais
pas il faut commencer à y croire là oui
j'y crois aujourd'hui crois un peu mais
ça sera peut-être dans 15 jours un mois
que je vais croire
et parce que se lever à 4h au matin
c'est très dur surtout avec le métier
que je fais
et toute une journée toute une journée
comme ça au boulot plus mon deuxième
boulot c'est pas un boulot c'est un
dérivatif bien sûr le football mais
arrivé chez moi à 20h entre 20h et
20h30 matin ou j tous les jours tous les
jours ça fait combien de temps que vous
levez à 4h du matin oh ça
fait ça fait 17 18 ans que je suis
toujours du matin alors ça fait la mine
ça fait combien de temps au fond euh 32
ans j'ai toujours travaillé au fond
alors j'ai à la mine j'ai j'ai gravé
tous les stades comme au football j'ai
essayé de concilier les
[Musique]
deux mon père il a fait 27 ans de mine
et j'étais embauché à la mine c'était le
moment de la récession et on m'a
embauché j'ai travaillé une semaine
après mon certificat d'étude en
1949 exactement le 7 juillet 14 ans j'ai
j'ai pass pardon j'ai passé mon
certificat d'étude fin juin et le 7
juillet j'étais auond votre casque là
vous allez le garder ou le rendre non
non non je vaux pas le garder non vous
aez envie de le garder non non
non un autre homme là ou ouais on va
aller vers le terrain
on l'impression que vous avez
définitivement oublié la mine là quand
on vous voit dans cette tenue non euh
oui un peu plus que cet après-midi oui
quand je suis avec les gsses à
l'entraînement je ne pense plus la mine
mais du tout du tout du tout mais là
vous est-ce que vous pensez que vous
allez encore encore vous souvenir de la
mine ou peu à peu vous allez l'oublier
assz vite au j'espère mais ça sera quand
même difficile comme je vous ai dit ce
matin vous avez 32 ans faire ce métier
là un métier que j'aimais bien quand
même ça sera difficile mais j'espère
l'oublier parce que sans maladie
professionnelle sans sans silicose 32 an
de fond quand même euh si je suis
reconnu silicosé quand même faut pas
dire que je je ne suis pas reconnu par
les médecins des mines mais je suis
reconnu silicosé quand même alors vous
pouvez courir entraîner les entraîner
les gosses oui j'essaie quand même
d'être sérieux à ce niveau-là
c'est-à-dire que suivre un régime assez
strict pour pouvoir concilier les deux
attention top le dernier le dernier plot
tu passes
latéralement tu reprends ce parcours et
arrivver au 16 m frappe au
but pied droit pied gauche Lionel pied
droit voil pied droit reviens
voilà c'est une véritable école de de
football là que vous dirigez oui c'est
c'est le début de l'école de football
c'est-à-dire que on essaie de recruter
les jeunes de 14 15 ans il passent 2 ans
avec moi et les meilleurs soit
intellectuellement ils sont bon ils
continuent l'école jusqu'à leur bac ou
si le football il prime que pour le
moment c'est le cas 90 % les gosses
abandonnent l'école et se
consacrent entièrement au football d'où
vient que
que cette région de lance porte une
véritable culte au
football B lance oui mais moi je crois
personnellement toutes les régions
industrielles portent le le culte du
football et pourquoi il y a un rapport
entre les
deux voilà parce que les régions
industrielles pour arriver à quelque
chose il faut
cravacher pour essayer de de de sortir
de l'anonymat
et le football c'est pas pareil vous
avez beaucoup cavaché moi
personnellement vous savez je suis parti
à zéro je me suis embauchché aux
ouillère et 14 ans et puis une semaine
j'étais au fond mais je ne regrette rien
qu'est-ce que vous voulez c'est l'AR de
la vie je ne regrette rien j'ai bossé
pour arriver à quelque chose je j'espère
que je suis arrivé des deux côtés de
l'autre côté j'étais quand même agent de
maîtrise supérieur ce côté-là le
football ça marche pas trop mal alors
euh
je suis
content c'est un bon
entraîneur un bon entraîneur ça doit
avoir quelle qualité ben être assez
sévère
quoi pas trop quand même parce que quand
tu es quand quand un entraîneur est trop
sévère ça marche pas avec les joueurs
non être sévère c'est quoi c'est vous
vous faire de faire faire des des
minutes en plus des des exercices en
plus parirentraînement quoi parir ouais
défense de rire sérieux le football
ouais ou ça fait combien de temps que
vous pensez au football tous les deux
ben ça fait 7 ans que je joue au
football 7 ans oui alors tu avais quel
âge tu as commencé 7 ans 7 ans toi aussi
non non moi j'avais 5 ans et demi quand
j'ai commencé 5 ans et demi qu'est-ce
que vous apprenez qu'est-ce que vous
voulez faire j'ai aucune idée de ce que
je vais faire plus tard B
une petite idée quand même oua on vise
le
football on vise leot
carrière il a pe d'él non
ou5 par Ann 65 jeunes qui arrivent à
devenir
professionnel il qu' une petite place
pour
vous personne ne vous dit que vous
rêvez avant
oui maintenant non je pas pourquoi qui
s'est passé entre les deux
B on a tous les deux été en stage de
présélection en équipe de France alors
depuis ce tempsl ça a
été ça après ça continué
quoi puis
voilà vous pensez peut-être que vous
serez un jour professionnel enfin c'est
pas on espère quoi enfin ce sera dur
vous voudriez ressembler à qui jouer
comme qui à personne personne non non
enfin - moi si jamais vous ne pouviez
pas être professionnel que
seriez-vous je pas du non
plus vous n'avez pas du tout pensé à à
cette
éventualité enfin je pense que ça
pourrait arriver mais j'ai pas d'autre
choix je sais
pas heureusement que j'ai ces goses là
que je me consacre j'oublie la mine vous
oubliez la mine je suis vraiment
décontracté c'est incroyable et et pour
moi c'est une seconde
jeunesse est-ce que malgré tout de temps
en temps ça ne vous inquiète pas de
savoir que que ces jeunes ne pensent
qu'au football je les préviens quand
même que vous leur dites ne vous faites
pas d'illusion voilà voilà mais je leur
préviens quand même que le travail
qu'ils font ici pour moi c'est pas du
travail perdu parce que depuis 8 9 ans
que je suis là je je ne dis pas que tous
les jeunes qui ont passés par mes mains
sont devenus professionnels mais la
majorité des gosses ont trouvé des clubs
de 3e 4e ou division d'honneur et qui
dit maintenant dans ces divisions là ils
ont plus de d'avantage d'être placés
qu'aux autres avec le football alors ils
jouent football et puis ils ont une
place c'estàdire une place de
comptabilité ouais j'ai envie de vous
demander à quoi ça sert le football bah
à quoi que ça sert le football
premièrement c'est un spectacle et
deuxièmement comme vous avez dit le
football surtout dans la région du Nord
et du pas decalis mais ça ne marche pas
toute une région grogne toute une région
grogne ce que tout le monde vit que pour
le football on a que ça dans la région
alors on a que ça c'est dur ce que vous
ditesou on a que
[Musique]
ça